hi Samuel lives here hope you've had a
fantastic bank holiday week end and I've
got a special guest I wanted to
introduce you to in a moment and he is a
HMO letting agent actually my brother
and a lot of people ask me questions
such as where do you hate mo tenants
come from who are they
what's the statistics between a viewing
and renting a rumor and all those types
questions so I'm an initiative Russell
leads and he's gonna give you some
interesting stats okay Russell who are
you then introduce yourself so well I'm
obviously Russell who kind of got me
into him first
um Samuels brother and we're actually
we're actually here at Leeds Festival
today we go in basically we manage a lot
of HMOs particularly what the stats were
where did we get them from what
percentages are someone our so forth so
we have here my spreadsheet data so I'm
gonna go look over here so effectively
result firstly how many viewings do you
typically do in an average month for
your HMO Baltus we're looking at August
at the moment so so far for August we've
booked in 46 viewings 46 wings and out
of those viewings do they all turn up no
so nice one of the problems of doom do
EG gets the prompting and they're not
they're out of the 46 38 of them we've
actually done so 46 viewings and only 36
have turned up 38 have turned up not too
bad so eight people have canceled
beforehand and you've had a none wasted
trip no it was still a wasted trip they
don't cancel they just don't show oh
geez not good
hey guys this is why you need a HMO
manager and so the number of let's we've
had from that is eighteen eighteen let
conversion right yeah I personally think
a 50% conversion rate is pretty high but
that's because the rooms that we give
you and I like all these rooms are the
rooms that we've given you you're going
through yeah so the rooms that we give
you a pretty good they are good they've
been well perhaps how we should
obviously normally decorate them and it
they are done to sort of a higher
standard than your typical HMO
they look really nice they're clean
they're lovely he says they done to a
high standard but he doesn't realize the
budget that we spend we have a very
small budget but we furnish them and
they look like a frickin show home not
your department but anyway yeah where do
you find all these tenants from is there
really that much of a demand for rooms
so yeah I would say there was but you've
got to look for it it's not the sort of
thing I mean like we're on Rightmove but
we only had one viewing from right moves
out those views any one of them so when
they'll come from so will a lot of them
came from spare room bed 30 from spare
room we had two from our web site one
from Gumtree three from room buddies and
nine from other sources okay don't don't
what are these other sources it depends
so sometimes it'd be like a
recommendation you know we do we do
things like leaflet drops and things all
out base where they haven't come from
one of our main marketing sort of
activities so surprisingly you don't get
that many from right moves no no right
right movies more for it's your single
net single that's yeah yeah and unlike
most Latin agents
quit moves they specialize in HMOs and
do single apps if a letter agent says we
do single let's but oh we can do HMOs
too don't trust them they need to be
hate to most specialists in order to
rent the rooms that love this bad boy so
what advice would you give to somebody
who was wanting to potentially rent the
rooms out themselves would you say don't
do that or would you say go for it oh
absolutely
I mean I think that if you live nearby
and you want to do it yourself great
thing to do but what I would say you've
got to be proactive you can't just stick
it up on Rightmove stick him up on spare
room and think they're gonna go cuz
they're not what you need to do is you
need to let you know what we do we troll
through the lists of all the ads and we
respond to them and we go around looking
for people and that's where you actually
get most viewings from it's not what we
would coming to you is you go into them
so do it but be proactive so I mean
you've got a really good conversion
right I mean doing 50% closing on the
viewings is pretty good it's better than
most
hmm managers what advice would you give
to somebody who's wanted to get a really
good conversion rate like yourself so
first of all I would say you've got our
good products by good products I mean
you gotta have a good house it's gotta
be close to us that he sends got really
good location that's desirable for
you know for your respective penthouses
could it be nice and attractive from the
outside
I wouldn't say from the outside although
it does help if it's not message got
weeds grow no you know it's got to be
clean I would say will be put if it's
ugly from the outside but it's nice and
like a show me the inside is that fine
the inside is the important bit mostly
their room and the kitchen I would say
they're the most important rooms at
negative uh but about have a
nice-looking kitchen is clean and nice
and have a good looking room that's
better so when they're doing all the
different viewings because a lot they're
just gonna view yours are gonna view
more
yeah you want a one that stands out
looks good and I think I could see
myself living here and location location
you got it like I said you've gotta be
near a city center you got to be near
something that they want it doesn't have
to be a city center it's gotta be near
somewhere where people want so for
instance near a hospital be near a
hospital you good because you've got a
lot of people that work in lost yeah
looking for rooms nearby or in a big
town center retail parks that kind of
stuff places where there are jobs people
want to be by work if there are jobs
there you good so part of its about the
product and what else the other thing is
about closing I mean one of the things
that we do is we take the contracts in
with us and it sort of act like it's
gonna go very very soon which it clear
honesty probably will do it's doing go
very soon if you want to reserve it you
can sign up here right now and you want
to be closing the whole time you want to
seal the deal so Russell my brother he's
based in the West Midlands so if you've
got rooms you want to rent out in the
West Midlands speak to this guy quick
move Ltd credit UK some really good
areas outside of the West Midlands I
mean West Midlands we've got
Wolverhampton as an alga article for so
it can be a bit more tricky
all I'm currently investing in Bradford
don't catch that Grimsby tat halt why
those areas because the rules are good
there's no article for the council's are
noise you can buy low rent high just
make sure then rooms are nice and
they're right near the center and for
more tips around property investing and
meeting more power team members and
getting strategies don't forget to
subscribe right here I'll see you very
soon so watch we're gonna have our
pudding now then
a lot by people saying what are the
ratio between empty rooms and full rooms
with HMOs how long does it take to rent
a room out also they ask forget that